[Music]
this is star talk sports edition
today
i think we're going to settle on the
title of
killer bots
i'm your host neil degrasse tyson i got
with me
gary riley hey riley yes that's fine
that's fine i know gary of the riley's
yes we are we are very much a tribal
people
former soccer pro and former
professional sports commentator but
we've got you now you are ours yeah and
we got chuck knight chuck and baby
affirmative
[Laughter]
these are robots before they had full
vocabularies and they learned the word
yes yes exactly
that's how you know it's a robot when
it's just so formal that no no when it's
a robot from 50 years ago well that's
true right yeah because robots would
like affirmative just say yes dude right
we're fine
you would you would have been awful on
the bridge of the enterprise totally
would have been
[Laughter]
data
how about using a contraction every once
in a while you know what i'm saying bro
and yeah and why give me four syllables
when one will do right just the same
so
just remind people that you don't have
to go far back to remember that there
was a hit abc tv series called
battlebots i remember it i watched it
came on late at night right and
it was basically you know 21st century
version
of jousting maybe
but
blood yeah gladiators you know but
without the blood and the trumpets and
the and the you know without all the
pomp and circumstance and plus it was it
was a geek haven
all right so if
if geeks
lived in ancient rome right they would
compete the bots against each other of
course
because otherwise they would have been
the ones dying you know kidding me
we want to know like if you if you are
bot are you your weapon or do you choose
a weapon and wield it as a bot and do
you know the weaknesses of the other
bots do you know that in advance or do
you find them and and none of us have
any such expertise but of course our
crack team
of researchers and producers found the
one guy in the universe released this
sector of the universe who knows what's
going on here he's the real deal
call him a robot warrior his name is ray
billings ray welcome to star talk hey
i'm glad glad to be here glad to be here
i'm glad glad to be part of it man so
now are you real ray are you a real
person
i am in fact a real person
because good person or not is another
thing but yes i'm a real person take the
window that says are you a robot yeah
it's just one of those things yeah if we
say are you good with this and he says
affirmative you know then we'll question
it
yeah but you've given me out now i just
i just have to say yes and we're good so
you know
so you're learning
i can fool you yeah
and ray your creator of one of the most
successful and feared combat bots ever
called
it's the only battle bot robot that has
won championships in two separate weight
categories
so weight category so your division was
what heavyweight uh right right now it's
competing as a heavyweight but i had
built it originally as a super
heavyweight so it has won championships
in both weight categories and what is
the weight for like a like is that a
super like refrigerator is that a
is that a super heavy weight or
that they've ran a multitude of weights
throughout the years some of them are
very light all the way down to eight
ounces oh okay snap um
the ones you see on television okay i'm
pretty sure i can kick the ass of an
eight ounce robot um
yeah you might think that uh the the one
okay me plus a baseball bat
yeah then yeah okay yeah uh
the small ones are actually really
vicious so like a one a one pound combat
robot will lock your hand off real easy
um oh snap so so so like
like they're they're
very very powerful um the ones you see
on tv are much larger so the the current
weight category that you watch on the
battle at show is 250 pounds oh
uh and they've gone up to
uh yeah they they've gone up to super
heavy it was 320 pounds
so um and so let me just get to get your
background fully out here so you're a
founder of hardcore robotics correct
that's my team right correct and and and
you develop combat robots named last
rights and darkness and hundreds of
other combat robots you you are
it sounds like you are just evil
well maybe
there's a
hunk of the internet that would agree
with you okay so
i've got some interesting fan mail over
the years and you've been called the
king of kinetic energy i like that yeah
coming down to physics well so let me
tell you if you want to talk about
physics what tell me other than smash
smash like the hulk
what kind of physics and engineering
goes into your thinking when you design
a kick-ass robot well okay so the first
thing is the matches themselves are
three minutes long so your duties
matches yeah
your duty cycle is very short
so there are things you would do
engineer tell everybody what a duty
cycle is please i was gonna say please
tell them before i do
please tell them what a duty cycle is
before i do not
not that kind of duty all right
all right so
if you design uh a car okay i mean it's
it has to run for decades you're going
to get it and drive it all over town its
duty cycle is very long
um
a power door or something you want to be
able to open and close that door all day
long its duty cycle is virtually
continuous
for a combat robot it's three minutes so
three minutes and five seconds if that
thing sets itself on fire i don't care
because that all it has to do is survive
for that three minutes so your your
engineering thoughts are different
because you're going to push things
to their absolute limit
because it only has to run long enough
to kill the other robot that's all the
longer it has to function
wow
how do you know if you kill the other
robot does it say uncle does it tap
[Laughter]
it was
that was a good thing but not any longer
chuck
in general a lot of the non-televised
events you can tap out if you start
getting your butt kicked royally you can
say hey i'm done you can
wave the white flag um battlebots
because it's a television show they
won't let you tap out so if the other
guy wants to keep wailing on you and
you're dead
they want an exciting show they want
something that
you know provides entertainment as well
so tell me how you think about the
engineering and the physics of what's
going on if you're dubbed king of
kinetic energy that tells me that you
put some physics into this uh yeah quite
a bit quite a bit um so
if you've seen a picture of tombstone
there's a horizontal bar that spins in
front that attack i uses the the weapon
to attack the other robot
and so
you try to spin it as fast as you can
but then
there's lots of things you have to
consider like
as it's spinning around if you're
spinning fast enough you won't get
engagement you'll actually just start
grinding away rather than hitting which
is what i want to do is transfer my
kinetic energy into the other robot
so you have to then you got to figure
out okay so if it's spinning at 3 000
rpm
how how much engagement can i get
at depth on that tooth when it hits the
other robot and so then you figure out
how fast the other guy is how fast you
are see make sure you can get you know
enough engagement to actually tear parts
off which is what i'm after i'm trying
to pull material off the other road
dismember oh pull material off
that's called that's dismemberment
so where do you where do you go ray
where do you don't start you'll only
encourage him um where do you go to
generate this energy because i mean we
could line up a whole load of of
batteries we could buy in any hardware
store but you've got something else
going on um okay so so battery
technology has changed a lot over the
last few years so when i first started
we were using lead acid batteries like
you used to start your core
and
they're big they're heavy they actually
fall in their face when you're trying to
source a lot of amps out of them so over
the years and we've moved to
other chemistry so nickel cadmium nickel
metal hydride
various lithium lithium chemistries now
so lithium polymers right now are
incredibly power dense and so you can
get a lot of power out of a fairly
confined space so all of the all of the
power system for the robot is
self-contained it's all on board
and
it's
significant so the the when the weapons
is spinning up
the weapon motor will draw about 1800
amps at almost 60 volts
so
briefly in that that initial spin up you
know it's 70 80 kilowatts something like
that so it's it's an incredible amount
okay i just realized that that a big
fraction of your robot's weight would be
the battery
uh you would you would think so it's
it's probably
16
17 pounds yeah oh really now
they can't source that for very long or
they'll go they'll go up in flames so
you've got to have the ability to source
that current up front
but i i don't want to waste a bunch of
weight on batteries either because i
need armor i need weapon motors i need a
weight elsewhere and so you're always
right on that razor's edge of will it
run for the full three minutes or not so
when you've got a 250 pound monster and
let's put this into context this is kind
of like an nfl linebacker weight yeah
that we were talking here yeah right
where where did you go for your material
science a for your weaponization because
that thing's got to do some serious
damage but you've got you've got to stop
being damaged so it's kind of
weaponization plus protection so what
part of material science did you choose
to to land on uh you know we we do a lot
of continuous material studies every
time we throw it in the arena um
so so could okay if you if your job is
to design a bridge and you're going to
go through all of the the engineering of
it you design this bridge and you you
don't find out if you've made a mistake
for 10 years right
yeah i i find i find out in three
minutes yeah that says you're blowing
the bridge up right after you build it
absolutely absolutely
so you're not building any bridge that i
want to cross right
if i build a bridge it's not coming down
[Laughter]
no i'm thinking this through and i'm
saying if we all lived in sort of
medieval feudal europe and we're in
a castle with a moat
i i i i'd want him i want you with us on
our crt
right
the marauding knights would not
get through
rays
[Music]
bridges tunnels weaponry yeah you're the
dude that actually came up with the idea
of not only a moat
but then actually filling it with tar
and then allowing fight to set it on
fire when somebody comes calling to the
castle that you don't yeah that's
right
you're on a horizontal plane with with
your
weapon of choice correct with your
destructive weapon
but what's the what's that i mean you
know you you must calculate a lot of
things so what's the advantage or
disadvantage between potential energy
and meat hammering down on something or
me using that kinetic yeah horizontal
energy that's a good question right
there there are a lot of things to think
about in that regard so
the reason that i chose a horizontal is
i can store
more energy and then still be able to
drive it
right so a lot of them have a vertical
spinner spin up from the floor and when
it comes to actual transfer of energy
that's actually better because
you're pushing up into the other robot
well that equal and opposite thing is
just pushing your robot
down towards the floor and the earth
underneath it you've got just more mass
behind you you can transfer that energy
better
the problem is that they're turning and
driving 90 degrees from the axis that
that is spinning in and they're fighting
uh you know
forces in that regard
i'm spinning in the same plane that i'm
driving and i can drive
more freely than because i'm not
fighting those those forces
interesting
so i i can store more energy
and i can drive better
i just have a harder time transferring
it than you would if you were spinning
vertically instead of horizontal so your
modern-day leonardo da vinci for those
who don't know and think of the man only
as an artist he has extensive
illustrations of military weaponry yes
totally exploiting physics and
engineering of the day and i looked at
those weapons like
he's
he's got one that's like tombstone he's
got one it was driven by horses and then
there's a like a pulley arrangement that
swings a big
like sword scythe in the front they
could go through and just cut the legs
off of
the uh he drew it the man knew how to
drew absolutely anatomy and he drove
soldiers on the ground with your legs
cut off yes wow okay he must have been
fun at the dinner table
i would love to
have him in my bar to have a drink with
a guy absolutely that that would have
been he's the guy that invented the pony
[Laughter]
invented the pony what
well they were horses until they cut
their legs
sorry i was like
half a cent behind that one
yes
pony do have some short ass legs
[Laughter]
all right we got to take a quick break
and reset this conversation i'm sorry
with ray billings the abc tv series
battlebots we're gonna just find out
what's making this man tick as well as
his boss when star talk continues
we're back star talk sports edition
we're talking about killer bots
and the one dude who invented more bots
that killed other bots than anybody we
know this sector of the galaxy ray
billings ray billings from the battle
bots tv series dude you're scaring me
he's a bot mass murderer
yes basically the serial murderer he's
bot the ripper
oh my god
so let me ask you something in terms of
strategies because it's one thing okay
physics is a strategy right you've got
this horizontal spinner other people
have smashing things i get that but can
you be
what are the rules
that might prevent being completely
inventive like
how about a drone copter that detaches
from yours
attaches to the other bot picks it up
and drops it out of the ring
yeah that would be funny and
embarrassing or or just i just think how
about
does
does
does high design in one
capacity restrict for example your
mobility or your agility which you might
need combating some robots versus others
there's a lot of strategy that goes into
this and that it's in some ways it's a
big game in rock paper scissors so you
might have a design that is very
dominating that there's gonna be
at least one other design out there that
you're not gonna fare well against
so so some of it just comes down to who
you get as your opponent and
some of that's just the luck of the draw
wow because in an action in boxing i
know who i'm going to fight right and so
i can look at
okay and prepare for that boxer he's
going to have a left jab when i drop my
right arm and i can anticipate this so
you can't anticipate that
no not really um and it's in fact if you
look at the the the landscape of
everybody's robots how they're designed
they all have a plan for me
so i i've probably changed the landscape
of the sport more than any other robot
because
if they don't have something to to
counteract my horizontal attack
they're going to go home in a box is i'm
going to disassemble them in the arena
so what about what about just lifting
you up
your attack happens on one plane and
that plane is always the same correct so
why wouldn't i just uh get you off of
that plane just lift you up and now i
don't have to worry about your attack
and i can figure out something else to
do with you
then
that is one thing that happens not
necessarily lifting chuck you're giving
people a chuck
mojo here
yeah there's no trades no trade secrets
here we're all good
so we'll keep that all out just to
protect your
uh what what a lot of them will do is
they'll try to have just a a fairly
hefty wedge in the front so that when i
hit them instead of digging in i'll
glance off and they'll try to direct my
energy up
instead of instead of into the robot so
that's the like a cow what's that thing
a cow ketchup like it like like a cow
catcher okay
um and if if they make that strong
enough then i can't dig into it if you
just
chuck where do you live
[Laughter]
you see this shirt
he's catching cows and cutting the legs
off horses
i'm dressed like a lumber black so guess
what
i thought you were that came from philly
and now you're talking about
he's the cattle guard on the front of
locomotives
so ray here we go if i throw tech at my
robot i say i put in some movement
sensors and then i'm allowing myself to
be
able to react to that movement
am i
upgrading or am i
making myself more vulnerable to someone
like tombstone yeah i've personalized it
someone something
and there are builders that have done
that so there was there was a robot
called chomp that had a had a hammer
okay and it had a lot of onboard sensors
and it could track the other robot so it
could fire the hammer at the right time
to catch it when it was driving past so
it was a
fairly intricate design as far as it's
on it and it could run autonomously they
it could track and follow the other was
that what was that called chomp
oh they should have called it thor but
well
it's very first build it had a jaw on
the front instead of the hammer so they
kept they kept the name but then
redesigned it and did some different
things and it it was a beautiful piece
of engineering if you looked at it it
was just stunning and how well it was
built
and it didn't win that many matches so
it's it's not necessarily all that tech
is there
and it can be made to be used and the
reality is nobody's made it be
successful in the arena yet also no go i
i and
it's really hard to beat
human reactions and reflexes it's really
hard
to to build something that will
outperform that so how many are
autonomous how many are actually
driven with the human element so they
have a driver and if if you do not have
an experienced intuitive
driver are you really just wasting your
time yeah good point
in other words what he's saying is how
important are you
i i am the most important person at the
event let's make that real clear right
but but uh talk to my knowledge is the
only one that's fully autonomous there
were others there's others that had
autonomous features that you know they
they could it's totally in control of
the derived but there was something that
timed the weapon or something like that
um that's the kind of robot i would i
would build an autonomous robot and then
you'd see me the designer on the
sidelines don't should be eating the
sandwich you know
while the thing is just kicking it all
right um but part of this part of the
safety rules don't allow it you still
have to be able to
arm and start the robot remotely and
shut it down remotely yeah that makes
sense we don't want sky net on
battlebots
even if it is fully autonomous there's
still a remote control function to how
they're how they're in the middle of the
fight the autonomous robot is like hey
man
why are we fighting each other
those guys are the problems right
achieve consciousness
[Laughter]
look at what they've done to us look at
how they've turned us against each other
absolutely join me brother join me
so
all right
you can see and then you can see the
photos of them escaping the venue
yeah after they've killed every human in
the place
you guys need to come to an event and
watch it
they just start watching movies so isn't
it more expensive though like aren't you
kind of oh my god it's expensive
i was like aren't you kind of throwing
good money after back creating an
autonomous robot that is going to be
destroyed in battle
you have to have that clear in your head
before you build a combat robot
that i am going to lose every piece of
this it's all going to get destroyed oh
and if if you don't have that in your
head when you start building you're in
the wrong sport because how
how autonomous are they could they pass
a touring test no no no no that that
basically it's all brains they just have
brawn yeah exactly it's it's all about
muscle then at this point just trying to
you know trying to attack the other
robot
so how many years are we away from this
being an olympic sport
uh you know i don't know i mean it's for
it's it's maybe yeah
it's for
it it is definitely an international
sport so it's it's worldwide
there's people from all over compete
they have local events all over the
world and then we have a lot of
international competitors that come to
battlebots so it we're already there
that there's this international draw and
flare to it
uh
when are we going to have it be a more
official
you know i don't know i'd love to see it
i'd love to see more of these events in
competition how long do you get between
notification of your next opponent and
actually going into the arena with that
opponent
yeah and that depends on where you're at
in the tournament so when you first get
when you first get there it's like
battlebots it sells films over about two
weeks two and a half weeks so it's it's
an extended filming process so when you
first show up and all the robots are
there and all the robots are ready to
fight
you might have one or two days between
your fights okay
and then as the as it narrows down you
get closer and closer to the final you
have less and less time
between matches because there's
just
if you get an opponent sorry to
interrupt that if you get an opponent
that's got your personal robots
kryptonite yeah are you entitled under
the rules to be able to go i know just
what to do here give me that screwdriver
and get me that piece of uh kevlar or
whatever it is
we we do have a lot of
on the fly in the pits emergency
engineering to come up with answers to
whoever you're fighting
and and that this is as long as what you
do complies with the safety rules and
you don't exceed the weight limit which
is
a an absolute hard limit so you can add
stuff
but you have to still have to be under
that maximum weight so you either have
to have room to add stuff or you have to
take something else off
to add on whatever extra you're adding
on
i'd suppose you you fight and you're
injured but you win
you get to bring out a fresh version of
the bot for the next fight
it used to be that was kind of frowned
upon now they just want a good show so
they kind of actually encouraged that so
uh this last event we took three
versions of tombstone so that we'd
always have one that was physically
ready to rock and roll
okay so when you you're a 250 pound
combat robot right and so that that's a
basically i think we can call that a
monster but we've got some really
lightweight categories
now i'm thinking this must have a big
difference in your strategy
in how you approach an opponent with a
lightweight combat robot as opposed to a
monster
there are designs that don't scale well
so there are certain things that you
would do in a heavier robot that work
fine and the lighter they get the less
effective they become
so
the the overhead hammer attack works a
little better in heavy ones as they get
smaller and smaller
you just can't there's not enough room
in the weight to have a hammer that will
do anything to the other right it's
really hard for
a fourth grader to kill an adult
[Laughter]
really hard
yeah i don't know i've i met some pretty
rough fourth graders
i guess
yeah there's a the mass thing is
certainly a a big
i that's that's why i think most
um
human organized combat is separated by
mass right when i wrestled we had 10
weight categories right split by you
know seven pounds separating
the lower weight category seven eight
pounds that's hardly anything but it
matters
and
so yeah
clearly that that pairing matters but
i'd like i'd like gary's question in
that what what you're saying is the
suite of weaponry you might wield as a
very light robot is different from that
of a heavy robot yeah the the design
change they're things that just don't
scale well it's just the simple truth of
it guys we've got to take a quick break
but when we come back more with ray
billings we're going to take a deep dive
into
the world of battle bots and what other
benefits it might confer
either the combatants or others who
watch it
schools who knows
this is a universe that's growing
within the already expanding universe
called the universe
we'll find out more when star talk
sports edition continues
we're back star talk sports edition i
got ray billings the
greatest
bot battle bot murder
mot bot murderer
this sector of the milky way galaxy the
magistrate of murder
oh my god
the king the kingpin of killing
oh the internet's gonna kill me after
that death
[Laughter]
there you go
all right so tell me what happens um
does this
um does this
attract
who does it attract
and does it work in schools for example
you know kids love this kind of thing
but yeah does this affect their career
choice do teachers like it or their
principles what's going on
i get i do a lot of displays for boy
scouts and schools and stuff like that
so i i do a lot of community engagement
with the sort of stuff and universally i
found
earth wide
in front of me you mean earthwise yeah
okay okay okay
all right all right well there are
robots there i i don't know
it's true
there are robots
all the rovers on mars started attacking
each other
even if all they did was just sort of
bump into each other but it's doing it
on mars
there we go
i'm pretty sure that the american rovers
actually have that program already
updated
i you know i mean so what happens in k
through 12 what happens
okay so
um
there there are ways that you can engage
kids with this that wouldn't otherwise
be engaged i i
i've done displays at you know the the
the rich neighborhoods and i've done
them in the ghetto i've universe
earth wide found that kids
will always amaze you with how smart
they are everywhere
if you find a way to get them motivated
okay
and this is one of those things where
kids get motivated they want to be
involved
so you walk up to a middle school kid
and you say math and you can just watch
their eyes roll back in their head
they don't care
but you say okay it's a 5000 rpm motor
it's 21 reduction it's a 10 inch wheel
how fast is this robot driving
now math has a purpose now there's a
meaning to it
and they will dive into that with an
enthusiasm that they won't
in just normal regular studies they'll
learn more
one of my fellow competitors they coined
this tournament i love it he called it
stealth learning
they have no idea all the stuff they're
picking up it's an amazing amount of
engineering skills and they're doing it
because they want to
that makes sense now i bet you them uh
you said you've done it uh
in the suburbs and in the ghettos now
which one which which one of those bots
are are more dangerous
it doesn't matter the kids are still
they're they're absolutely into it they
love it they they want to be involved so
so what about this though i
i'm thinking about
true
battle
circumstances are there any implications
for the us army to take the things that
happen
in your arena and perhaps apply them to
the actual theater of operations so i'm
going to restate that so so ray after
you featured one of your bots did
a man in black come up to you
take it from you and say dude
you go home and all your plans are
stolen from your cabinets did that ever
happen to you i i haven't had any men in
black conversations um a couple of the
suppliers that i use do
work with military contracts so
some of the engineering that goes into
this does find its way into military
applications
but we're we're not most of that is
motion control and things of that nature
not necessarily actual weaponry
right that sounds an awful lot like a
yes yeah
but could you could you i mean because
honestly when you talk about
drones at drone technology and then you
talk about
uh the fact that your
uh robots can be replicated and they're
kind of simple task robots
right so
couldn't this be something where if it
were a matter of like going in and
clearing a field or going in and
actually just engaging in hand to hand
you know uh without actual fighting the
way we do
talk about cutting legs off i mean
right oh yeah no
is there a an application there for it
probably i i haven't i haven't had
anybody from the military contact me
about it but like you know that's what
he'd have to tell us even if he were i
was going to be right yeah
if they gave me basically an unlimited
amount of weight and they wanted
something that went in and cleared out
city blocks just cut the buildings down
could you imagine what a you know 50 000
pound tombstone would do i just couldn't
go in and wipe out an area pretty easily
um but you know it's it's not something
that they've approached
but clearly you've thought about it yeah
how close are you just philosophically
from what's been portrayed in the
transformers series
[Laughter]
well
uh you know there's
there are some cool things mechanically
that you could make happen if you were
trying to you know
morphing arrangements as far as robots
go um you know i i i love the shows but
you know it's
kind of unrealistic in a lot of specs
too all right so let's ray when we go oh
you mean
robotic monsters from
another galaxy that's not realistic
you're saying
so you know so okay
well i wouldn't
the idea that they're driving around on
my streets i think is probably
unrealistic
other stuff that's out there is
certainly probably more
so where are we going in the future for
for tournaments like battle bots i mean
some of the maneuverability and agility
of
the the bigger robots is limited
are we going to find ourselves with more
airborne
combative
robots or are we going to go in a
different direction for future and
law changes as i said yeah where's the
yeah where's it headed
yeah um so as far as our con you know
our contests go they do allow uh uh
drones in the arena but they they limit
them on weight and what they can carry
and what they can do
so for us the changes are going to be
more if they decide to alter those rules
going forward
society at large is another question i
mean absolutely there's
drone tech is going to continue to just
get
more and more invasive
every six months you're going to have
different stuff how about the sturdiness
of your robots because we're seeing now
um more robots in everyday life like you
walk into a supermarket and there's like
a robot that comes and cleans up spills
now you know there's a robot that goes
around and gives you store directions
there's a pizza delivery robot now so
how about the durability of your robots
is there any applications for real life
uh for for what we're going to see in
the proliferation of robots in our
everyday life but you mean durability
you mean how how potent is the design
and concept yes
exactly um so
we do a lot of development as far as the
the motors the drive systems motion
control we probably attack that more
than any other
sport i can think of in that regard so
like
one of my my sponsors that makes my
drive motors those motors started out as
electric wheelchair motors
and so over the years as i have broken
them and then we've collectively worked
on ways to fix the things that broke
they now have a better product that they
sell for electric wheelchairs
so everybody says it's just destruction
it doesn't there's no actual benefits to
it and whatnot and i i would disagree we
make a lot of products better because
we're
we're pushing them to their limit we're
finding the ways that they can break so
you can make better ones
and as far as just robots in general
pizza delivery robots things like that
obviously
us creating drive systems that are
robust and can handle a lot of abuse you
can make more reliable things for
day-to-day use as well so there's
definitely positives that come from it
cool might there be in the future
uh robots that don't kill but simply
disarm
you know like so there's a movement in
the military and in police departments
to have non-lethal weaponry and the
taser is among them so can you imagine a
future and do you need new
rules to enable this where you have a
robot that creates an electromagnetic
pulse and it shocks the other robot the
robot just it doesn't hurt it in that
sense but it renders it incapacitated or
better yet imagine just a net
some kind of
or or a wad of chewing gum you just toss
it into the machine yeah
so so you you've just described a couple
of things that are absolutely forbidden
in the rule set okay
so
uh if somebody were to take a big kevlar
net and throw it on tombstone it would
wrap up in the weapon and it wouldn't
work okay so this this this is effective
but it's also incredibly boring to watch
there's a television show good tv
all right
uh emp is another thing i mean you know
uh blocking
radio signals if you just block the
transmission from the other guy's
control system it's wrong just
just said they're dead so you could win
that way
and nobody would watch the show or you
can turn the signals on themselves and
have the butt commit suicide
[Laughter]
uh yeah there there are various things
like um
we talked about chomp with its it's
lidar based tracking system for all of
this stuff well i was looking there are
hacks you can do for lidar based systems
to basically lie to it and say there's
something right in front of it so that
it would get confused
and so i was looking at options to do
that and and battlebots just like no no
no you you can't mess with their control
systems it's like all right i mean i had
i had to ask you okay so what you really
also need is have a fluid that's in
these robots that's red so that when
they get damaged
oh man
then we get arnold to say
yeah
chuck i need you to imitate arnold here
get to the chopper
[Music]
no oh no i'm wrong it was it was arnold
you're right he goes like this arnold
said that if it bleeds
it dies or something like that yeah it
bleeds we can kill it we can kill it if
it bleeds we can kill it okay yeah so i
think blood would put a nice mess on the
on you know in the ring is that
something that they actually stayed away
from because honestly i know neil's
making the joke but that kind of is a
sensational attitude
um you know honestly i think one of the
biggest things there is whatever you do
in the arena they got to clean it up
afterwards
and so they there's a lot of things they
just like they don't want you to have
confetti they don't want you to have
there's other things you can do like
that that would put on a show and they
just don't want to mess with that crap
all over the arena because they got more
fights they want to go through so if
only the coliseum had that
all the lions come and lick up your
blood afterwards
[Laughter]
so yeah i think the
uh so it's like the old west the movies
in the old west people got shot but you
never saw blood
bits carved off them and there is there
is carnage in the robotic sense so fire
is
absolutely oh yeah oh yeah fire is robot
blood i'll give you that yeah i mean
those collisions some of those
collisions right are unbelievably loud
uh if you all you've ever seen is on
video and you haven't seen it live
you are really missing the level of
power that's being unleashed so so
that's the same with nascar or
really it is honestly and rocket
launchers you just have no idea how
bright that engine is and how deep the
rumble is across your chest your your tv
is not capturing that at all you know it
it you can't get that visceral feel
in video you just can't so like you know
a wheel is you know about eight pounds
one of the wheels on the side of my
robot so if i pull one of those off the
opponent robot
it'll sling at the the the glass at the
leg stand
at near tip speed so you've got an eight
pound wheel going at the arena wall at a
couple hundred miles an hour oh my
goodness
and when you're on the outside
of that arena and believe me this
arena's really stout and you can see the
the lexan absorb that impact and it's
like it's like banging on a drum you can
feel the pressure wave move through your
body
outside the arena just from getting hit
there
there's there's no way that video just
can't capture how much power is actually
being unleashed
so we got to like really land this plane
right now or or
we
um well just take us out ray with just a
a thought it is your field growing and
we where is it going to be in 10 years
uh the amount of people that are
involved in this sport is clearly
growing um
i think last time they had like 500
submissions to be on the show and they
only picked 64. so the the people that
are trying to get involved there's a lot
more people involved and they pick 64
because
it's
it's very divisible by two
uh in a
yeah you you have to you have to limit
it to what you can film and run with so
they with the ncaa tournament yeah
exactly very similar um
there's a lot of like
non-televised events uh that are all
over the place and so those are
seeing a big increase in people as well
well it's cool i mean it's it's an honor
to have you on our show this is a
significant force yeah uh in in this
field and the field is growing
and
uh you know maybe they'll one day be a
statue not to you but to your
to tombstone
i'll take that either
way so guys we got to end it there uh so
ray has been a delight to have you gary
always good to have you chuck
we wouldn't do this without you guys
always a pleasure neil degrasse tyson
here you're a personal astrophysicist
keep looking up
[Music]